madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale
monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
le président du Sénat mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés
mesdames et messieurs
pour que la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale prenne la parole dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat
il faut un grand événement
et c'est un effet un moment historique
que nous vivons et un grand honneur que
vous nous faites votre majesté qui
connaît bien la France mais qui vient
pour la première fois en tant que
souverain du Royaume-Uni de
Grande-Bretagne et d'Irlande du Nord
cette visite se devait de comporter une
dimension parlementaire
car il faut le reconnaître si le
Royaume-Uni réclamait des royalties sur
l'idée du Parlement toutes les
démocraties du monde lui seraient
redevable
en France
dès le siècle des Lumières le partage du
pouvoir entre exécutif et législatif et
l'admiration des esprits éclairés
si Montesquieu théorise la séparation
des pouvoirs il en observe la pratique
de l'autre côté de la Manche et c'est
aussi à Londres que Voltaire puis
l'inspiration de ces lettres anglaises
Mirabeau quant à lui plusieurs fois
victimes de l'arbitraire royal vénère
tout particulièrement la Béa Scorpus
britannique et c'est donc sous le titre
d'observation d'un voyage anglais qu'il
publie sa critique des prisons d'État
françaises
dans ce livre il crédite nos voisins vos
sujets
d'un plus grand respect des droits de
l'homme que cette nation a si
glorieusement appris
allusion évidente à la Glorieuse
Révolution de 1688
lui-même publie son pamphlets un siècle
plus tard en 1788 et si l'année suivante
la volonté le même Mirabeau défi le roi
du France en lui opposant la volonté du
peuple incarné par la première Assemblée
nationale c'est tout simplement qu'il
veut acclimater en France le modèle
britannique de monarchie
constitutionnelle
finalement ce sont presque les Anglais
kéfirent la Révolution française la
famille régnante n'était pas d'accord et
la France évolua vers un autre système
la République née le 21 septembre il y a
231 ans jour pour jour
ainsi ont toujours vécu nos deux peuples
s'observant
s'influençant longtemps rivaux mais
depuis plus d'un siècle toujours allié
pour défendre la démocratie et les
droits de l'homme
le calendrier mémorial est là pour nous
le rappeler l'année prochaine en 2024
nous célébrons tout à la fois les 120
ans de l'entente cordiale et le 80ème
anniversaire du débarquement nous nous
reverrons donc comme le chantier
verraline pour continuer de sceller ce
pacte d'amitié et selon partenariat qui
nous unit sur ce qui est essentiel
aujourd'hui
la guerre est revenue sur le sol
européen
et dès lors que les valeurs les plus
fondamentales se trouvent menacées par
un usage illégal et illégitime de la
force nos deux pays se retrouvent une
fois de plus du même côté celui du droit
international et du respect des droits
de l'homme
deux membres permanents du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies deux membres
de l'OTAN de démocratie d'influence
capable de s'entendre cela compte dans
un monde en proie aux tentatives de
déstabilisation et de désinformation
enfin en tant que femme
première présidente d'une assemblée
parlementaire française je voudrais
saluer la mémoire de ces femmes qui
plutôt qu'en France ont su faire évoluer
les mentalités pour que soit reconnue
les mêmes droits aux deux moitiés du
genre humain
j'aurais donc une pensée pour ces
suffragettes anglaises qui opèrent gain
de cause dès 1918 et je veux croire que
c'est en observant les femmes
britanniques leur engagement leur
civisme dans les épreuves de la guerre
et du Blitz que le général de Gaulle
signal ordonnance du 21 avril 21 avril
1944 qui rendit enfin les Françaises et
lectrices et éligibles
à Londres aussi pendant la guerre un
jeune français qui avait rejoint la
France Libre découvrit qu'on pouvait
acheter en pharmacie des produits
anti-conceptionnels permettant aux
femmes de contrôler leur natalité il
s'appelait Lucien nevirt futur député et
futur sénateurs qui obtiendra en 1977 la
légalisation de la pilule en France
au moment où dans le monde et jusque
dans de grandes démocraties les droits
des femmes sont remis en question sur la
base d'un discours nataliste agressif il
est bon de rappeler cet épisode qui est
beaucoup plus qu'une anecdote la liberté
ne se segmente pas on est libre ou on ne
l'est pas
et nous voulons l'être dans toutes les
dimensions de la vie
si
nos deux démocraties continueront
d'avancer ainsi vers notre idéal commun
de liberté et de respect de la personne
humaine
chacune à son pas
chacune à sa manière mais toujours main
dans la main quand il faut être ferme
ainsi je sais qu'ensemble nous
avancerons et ferons avancer le monde
sur la préservation de l'environnement
et de la biodiversité cause pour lequel
nous savons votre investissement
personnel depuis votre jeunesse sur cet
enjeu majeur sur cette grande question
du Millénaire
Marianne et Britannia resteront deux
sœurs
comme le déclarant Winston Churchill à
la Chambre des communes
le Tout-Puissant dans son infini sagesse
n'a pas jugé bon de créer les Français à
l'image des Anglais
et il disait aussi la France et la
Grande-Bretagne ont trouvé le chemin de
la liberté par des voies bien
différentes mais tant qu'elles feront
causes communes il sera bien dangereux
de les provoquer et bien difficile de
les abattre
il est impossible en quelques minutes de
résumer des siècles de voisinage et de
partenariats multiples mais je sais que
nous nous comprenons pour continuer à
faire ainsi cause commune nos deux pays
qui se sont mis d'accord pour restaurer
et entretenir la Tapisserie de Bayeux
seront donnés
de l'histoire c'est tout le sens de
votre visite et c'est pourquoi je suis
fière et heureuse de vous dire au nom de
la représentation nationale bienvenue en
France
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale monsieur le secrétaire d'État
aux Affaires étrangères au commnuels et
au développement
Mesdames et Messieurs les Ambassadeurs
mes chers collègues parlementaires
c'est un moment inédit que nous fait
vivre votre Majesté en nous faisant
l'honneur de s'adresser dans cette
hémicycle du Sénat à la représentation
parlementaire française
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
multicellulaire de nos deux pays un
souverain britannique va prendre la
parole devant le Parlement français
réunis dans sa composition bicamérale et
dans sa diversité politique
vous me permettrez de souhaiter la
bienvenue à la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale et à vous tous chers collègues
députés qui siégé aujourd'hui
parmi vos collègues sénateurs
j'ai le plaisir également de saluer les
membres de la Chambre des communes et de
la Chambre des Lords qui se sont joints
à nous ce matin
vous avez tenuir à réserver au Parlement
français le discours public que vous
prononcerez dans votre visite d'État
c'est dire l'estime nouée entre la plus
ancienne des nations parlementaires
le Royaume-Uni et le parlementarisme
français
de l'aviation des droits le Royaume-Uni
a ouvert la voie au parlementarisme
moderne
il faut avoir assisté comme
Châteaubriand
aux séances du Parlement britannique
pour s'exclamer dans les Mémoires
d'Outre-Tombe je le cite la liberté
contenue dans les limites de l'ordre
sembler ce débattre à Westminster fin de
citation Chateaubriand
la démocratie parlementaire
j'en suis persuadé le plus sûr antidote
pour juguler les passions politiques
et entre nos deux pays c'est bien de
passion dont il s'agit
parfois ennemis souvent alliés
longtemps concurrent le Royaume-Uni et
la France ont distillés
dans les heures sombres le Royaume-Uni
fut un refuge pour tous les Français
contre un exil il fut même un temps en
juin 1940 où la capitale de la France
c'était en quelque sorte transporter à
Londres pour édifier ensemble une digue
commune au totalitarisme et à l'empire
de la brutalité
dans l'adversité se réalisait après bien
des tumulte la vision prophétique de
Victor Hugo qui a siégeait ici sur ces
bancs
l'Angleterre toujours sera soeur de la
France
écrivait Victor Hugo
aujourd'hui
alors que nous nous apprêtons à
commémorer au printemps prochain le 80e
anniversaire du débarquement en
Normandie
le destin du Royaume-Uni demeure
intimement lié
au continent européen
le brexit SIR n'y a rien changé
votre nation est un acteur primordial de
la sécurité en Europe
le Royaume-Uni et la France
deux nations de tradition militaires
dont l'une la vôtre n'a jamais été
envahi
sauf par Guillaume le Conquérant
français avant l'heure
oui le Royaume-Uni et la France se sont
à de multiples reprises éprouvées mais
toujours respecté depuis longtemps de
cordiales il y aura bientôt 120 ans elle
se tiennent côte à côte
elles sont toujours dit fidèles à leur
vocation en se portant ce cours de
l'Ukraine agressé et meurtri
vous avez choisi cire comme la reine
Elizabeth II lors de sa visite d'État en
2004 de vous rendre au Sénat
au-delà du respect porté à la reine dont
je tiens à saluer la mémoire nous
voulons y percevoir un hommage au
territoire de la République que les
souverains britanniques ont si
assidûment parcourus et que le Sénat
représente un hommage à cette diversité
de territoires et de paysages dont la
préservation vous tient cire tellement à
cœur et qui constitue l'une des grandes
causes de notre temps
les collectivités territoriales de nos
pays au travers notamment des communes
on nous est temps de relations entre
elles
elles sont le socle le plus solide de
notre amitié
à travers les territoires
se forgent le génie d'une nation cette
idée n'est pas mienne elle provient du
plus français des historiens
britanniques
Théodore Zeldin dans l'histoire des
passions françaises et concédons le
oui concédons le à notre fierté
nationale il faut bien un historien
britannique de grands talent pour
réussir à décrypter les méandres des
passions françaises
sir sir
rares sont les pays européens qui comme
le Royaume-Uni et la France ont préservé
une même aspiration la considérer le
monde dans sa globalité
et tisser autant de liens de solidarité
avec les pays les plus vulnérables
avec un constat partagé
l'exercervation des fractures Nord-Sud
ne sert que les ambitions de puissance
des gouvernants qui les attisent le
néocolonialisme et le fait d'État
prédateurs et non des colonisateurs
d'hier
la France et le Royaume-Uni disposent
des ressorts nécessaires pour proposer
un autre horizon des coopérations
équilibrées la sécurité un développement
qui soit durable et une attention
particulière à la jeunesse de ces pays
le moment le moment me semble venu de
rassembler les grandes familles du
Commonwealth et de la Francophonie pour
quelle force une ambition et un langage
commun ce que préfigurait avec humour le
général de Gaulle
qui se confiait à Winston Churchill et
je le cite
plus vous progressez en français et plus
vous comprenez mon anglais
cette formule me va assez bien aussi
pour mon anglais
[Applaudissements]
sire
Sa Majesté la Reine Elizabeth
avait déclaré en 1996 lors d'une autre
visite d'État
celle du président Jacques Chirac
Londres je la cite
s'il est vrai que nous ne conduisons pas
du même côté de la route
il est tout aussi vrai que nous avançons
dans la même direction
de ce trait d'esprit
qui nous paraît à nous Français si
typiquement britannique so british
nous distinguons une vérité essentielle
nos chemins peuvent être différents
il divergent même parfois mais par une
constante qui défie les règles de la
logique et de la géographie de Londres
il nous ramène toujours à Paris et de
Paris à Londres ainsi s'incline le
cartésianisme français devant l'humour
et d'esprit britannique
Sir maintenant à travers les
parlementaires réunis c'est la nation
française tout entière qui vous écoute
merci
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est le président madame la
Présidente
mesdames les sénatrices et messieurs les
sénateurs
les députés
merci mille fois pour votre mot très
émouvant
je suis flatté d'avoir été invité par
les présidents de vos deux chambres à
palais ici dans cette illustre enceinte
qui a été d'une manière ou d'une autre
la chambre haute du parlement français
depuis 799
je suis bien conscient que ma visite
précède la rentrée officielle des deux
chambres de votre Parlement et je ne
peux que vous présenter mes excuses
d'avoir
interrompu votre peau
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
très touché par votre présence à tous
aujourd'hui
la longévité de votre démocratie on est
refléter aussi
dont la langue amitié qui lit nos
nations et nos peuples
notre partenaire construit sur une
expérience partagée demain absolument
vital alors qu'ensemble nous confrontons
les défis de ce monde
tout simplement le Royaume-Uni sera
toujours un des alliés les plus proches
et un des meilleurs amis de la France
il y a un monde épouse et moi-même avons
commencé cette visite à la tombe du
soldat inconnu
là nous avons quand même réussi tout ce
qui sont tombés pour défendre les
libertés si chères à nos deux pays
au cours de cette grande nation nous
avons rendu un hommage si l'ancien et
solidaire debout
avec vous comme nos pays se sont tenus
côte si souvent dans l'histoire
amusement
à l'Arc de Triomphe il y a 16 mois
qu'avec cette générosité qui vous
caractérise vous aviez célébré le jubilé
de platine de ma très chère mère feu la
reine Elizabeth II à cette occasion le
président Emmanuel Macron avait décrit
feu Sa Majesté comme étant le fil d'or
qu'il y est nos nations
été émue sont comme une mesure par les
hommages qui lui ont été rendus dans
toute la France
ce matin
j'ai relu les traits touchant maux de
condoléances que vos excellence
président de l'Assemblée nationale et du
Sénat ont écrit à cette occasion
vous avez décrit ce renne comme et ont
un cane avec Guinée la permanence de la
démocratie britannique et quel aimait la
France la France l'aimait
je ne peux vous décrire ce que c'est mon
signifié pour moi et pour ma famille
je peux seulement pour remercier et
remercier le peuple de France pour la
grande bonté que vous avez exprimée à
notre égard et à celui de notre peuple à
un moment de tel tristesse
dans la riche et complexe taperie de la
relation entre la France et le
Royaume-Uni le fil d'or que représentait
ma mère
brillera pour toujours
je souhaite qu'elle nous inspire à
continuer de tisser des liens entre nous
deux pays avec détermination avec espoir
et avec amour
les jeunes
à la fois
les exemples de ma grand-mère et de ma
défunte mère
la France a fait partie intégrante du
tissu de ma propre vie pour eux autant
que je m'en souvienne d'aussi loin que
je m'en souviens d'ailleurs j'ai été
frappée lorsque je me suis rendu compte
que c'était ma 35e visite officielle ici
en France et à chaque fois que je viens
je suis vraiment marqué frappée par la
chaleur de l'accueil dont je bénéficie à
chaque fois et par toutes les bonnes
choses que nous pouvons faire ensemble
lorsque la France et leur Ionie
travaillent ensemble
là à l'occasion de ma première visite
d'État en France je reste plus que
jamais convaincu du caractère
indispensable de la relation entre nos
deux pays
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés au
plus grand défi de notre
et nous continuons
à travailler pour poursuivre les travaux
de ceux qui nous ont précédés lorsque le
général de Gaulle c'est adressé au
peuple français depuis Londres en juin
1940 il a dit la chose suivante
rappelez-vous la chose suivante la
France n'est pas seule elle n'est pas
isolée elle peut faire bloc avec les
Britanniques
de Gaulle
avait raison de croire en outre alliance
de jour avant l'appel du 18 juin
le gouvernement de sor Winston Church il
avait
proposé à la France une union politique
indissoluble qui aurait permis eau de
peuples de continuer à se battre pour la
justice et la liberté en tant qu'un seul
pays
et deux mois seulement après cette radio
Diffusion historique mon grand-père le
roi George VII portant fièrement
l'insigne rouge de la Légion d'honneur a
rejoint de Gaulle à mort volcan à côté
d'aldochotte afin de passer en revue
2500 soldats des Forces Françaises
Libres
la détermination commune qui a été
exprimée ce jour-là a permis nous a
permis de traverser
ces années difficiles douloureuses de la
guerre et nous ont mené ensemble vers la
victoire
démonstration de notre engagement
envers la liberté et la démocratie reste
d'actualité
aujourd'hui à nos fausses aimer sont
très ensemble au sein de la fausse
expéditionnelle conjointe
franco-britannique cette proie ensemble
avec les troupes de maintien de la paix
de l'ONU et par le Conseil de sécurité
de l'ONU le G7 et le temps
assure mon Somme où l'on se sensibilité
jointe pour la sécurité européenne et
mondiale
aujourd'hui
plus de 91 depuis que nous ne sommes pas
tous côte à côte pour la libération de
l'Europe nous faisons face encore une
fois à une agression injustifiée sur
notre continent
notre détermination et notre alliance
sont plus importantes
importantes que jamais
on semble nous nous tenons aux côtes du
peuple ukrainien avec une solidarité
[Musique]
ensemble nous sommes inébranlables dans
notre détermination que l'Ukraine Trion
fera et que nos libertés si chers
une fois de plus montré combien de temps
de choses qui nous sont chères sont
fragiles alors que nous faisons bloc
face à l'agression militaire nous devons
ensemble
œuvrer afin de protéger le monde de ce
défi
existentiel le plus grand défi de tous à
savoir le réchauffement climatique le
changement climatique et la destruction
catastrophique de la nature
pour la maille partie de l'histoire
l'homme a dû combattre la nature pour se
vivre
dans ce siècle il commence à comprendre
que pour se vivre il doit la protéger
cette vision et donc plus pertinente en
ceinture
malgré l'ampleur et la sévérité du défi
auquel notre planète est confrontée
il est encore jeune de voir les mesures
prises par nos gouvernements nous
citoyens est de plus en plus par le
secteur privé
je prends cet depuis longtemps que nous
entreprises peuvent jouer un rôle
sensiel on travaille en partenariat et
on amené avec le gouvernements et nos
populations et investir des milliards
pour développer les solutions qui
permettront une transition réussie vers
un monde durable
avec le président Macron seront contre
cet après-midi des chefs d'entreprise
français et britanniques dont la
collaboration l'innovation et les
investissements dans une croissance
propre et la préservation de notre
précieuse biodiversité font partie d'un
lit de chez Mondial essentiel
j'ai réfléchi aux opportunités que
partage les membres de commande et de
l'Organisation internationale de la
Francophonie
j'espère vivement qu'il y aura des
possibilités de collaboration future par
exemple pour trouver une façon de
renforcer la coabulation matière de
développement durable
les
ment travail en partenariat afin de
relever tant de défis à l'échelle
mondiale néanmoins comme toujours ce
sont nos peuples qui sont le véritable
moteur de notre relation
notre amitié et nos liens chaleureux se
renforcent à chaque nouveau contact
entre nous
[Musique]
on le retrouve également dans cette joie
que l'on retrouve à chaque fois dans la
culture de l'autre et cela nous rappelle
à chaque fois combien nous partageons de
choses des millions d'entre nous se
rendent dans nos pays respectifs chaque
année et c'est une joie que nous
redécouvrons aujourd'hui après la
pandémie
des dizaines de milliers de fans de
rugby britannique
suivent actuellement leur équipe
nationale partout en France et ils
peuvent ainsi jouir du spectacle
fantastique qui est la coupe de rugby
d'ailleurs mon fils à ma belle-fille en
font partie
et même lorsque nos équipes nationales
se font face sur le terrain
elles le font
en faisant preuve d'admiration mutuelle
et en portant le même respect aux règles
du jeu et d'ailleurs je dirais
simplement pas de coups bas et que le
meilleur gagne
[Applaudissements]
bien entendu il y a des centaines de
milliers de nos concitoyens qui ont
décidé de s'établir de façon permanente
dans nos pays respectifs cet échange
tout à fait vivant entre nos peuples
nous rendent à la fois plus fort plus
heureux et plus prospère
des autres comme ils l'ont toujours fait
mêlant l'ancien et le nouveau et créant
des œuvres complexes et enrichissantes
des inoubliables images de Londres de
Claude Monet
et de bruit à londonienne qui fascinait
tant les visiteurs français
au plus récentes représentation sur
iPad de David des paysages changeants de
Normandie en passant par la
collaboration de votre fils entre le
design imprisanique pour Smet et le
musée Picasso à Paris il existe une
université dans notre décision
artistique partagée
en effet en ce moment même ma chère
épouse célèbre cette collaboration
artistique en lançant le premier prix
les élèves franco-britannique qui
récompense des oeuvres de fiction
contemporaine exceptionnelles
publiée en français et en anglais à
l'extraordinaire Bibliothèque nationale
de France
mon épouse et moi-même nous rendrons à
Bordeaux la première ville jumelée avec
une ville au Royaume-Uni Bristol c'était
en 1947 ce lien commun
n'est qu'un lien parmi la grande
quantité de connexion qui existe entre
nos villes nos villages nos communautés
nos entreprises et nos établissements
d'enseignements ce sont nos peuples
grâce à toutes ces actions
menées communement qui écrivent chaque
nouveau chapitre de notre histoire afin
que nous puissions léguer aux prochaines
générations un monde plus prospère plus
sûr et les jeunes doivent donc être au
cœur de nos entreprises communes
ce matin je me réjouis donc de rejoindre
des jeunes de 19e arrondissement de
Paris et de Saint-Denis qui sont aidés
dans leur incession professionnelle par
le biais d'initiative society
en soutenant des jeunes nous
investissons dans notre avenir à un
investissement qui sert à remporté
Dinan d'innombrables fois
monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente Mesdames Suisse et Messieurs
les sanitaires mesdames et messieurs les
députés
il y a près de 120 ans mon
arrière-grand-père le roi Édouard 7
c'est un gorgée au nombre de
liens entre nos deux pays
ce lien fut sanctifié par les sacrifices
incommensurables de siècle dernier et
polype de notre projet commun
aujourd'hui
il est entre nos mains après avoir été
transmis avec fierté de père en fille de
mère en fils tout comme il a été à
travers les générations de ma propre
famille
pendant le temps qui met accordé en tant
que roi
je m'engage à faire tout ce qui est mon
pouvoir et dans mon pouvoir pour
renforcer la relation indispensable
entre droit et la France
et aujourd'hui je vous invite à vous
joindre à moi dans cet effort
ensemble notre potentiel est illimité
c'est pourquoi nous devons chérir
et entretenir notre en tant que
renouvelons la pour les générations
futures afin qu'elles deviennent je le
propose également une entente pour la
dirigibilité pour répondre plus
efficacement à l'Agence mondiale en
matière de climat et de biodiversité
un engagement les uns envers les autres
et envers les valeurs que nous partons
suffisamment
un engagement inspiré par l'exemple du
passé et on corrigé à relever les
immenses des filles du monde qui nous
entourent
en tant que voisin ami partenaire et
allié il n'y a pas de défi que nous ne
puissions relever comme nous l'avons
fait si souvent par le passé
allons de l'avant avec espoir et courage
et faisons-le ensemble
merci
des applaudissements qui nous feraient
rêver madame la pression et moi-même
dans nos hémicycles respectifs
et Messieurs les parlementaires mesdames
et messieurs merci de rester un instant
à votre place pendant que la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale et moi-même
allons reconduire sa Majesté en le
remerciant de sa présence ce matin
devant député sénateurs dans cette
hémicycle merci cire
[Applaudissements]